hi i'm abby and this is a quick look at
how cloud code makes getting started
with secret manager
easy hard coding sensitive configuration
data
like database passwords and api keys
into strings is usually not a good idea
for your code base
secret manager securely stores the
sensitive data
in secrets a project global object
that's available to your application
at build or runtime cloud code makes it
easy to replace sensitive data in your
code base with secrets that are stored
securely
on google cloud with secret manager you
can create and integrate secrets without
leaving your ide
no matter what type of application
you're creating cloud code is available
for jet brains ids
vs code and cloud shell editor i'm going
to run this demo in pycharm
when you run your service in one of our
environments we make it easy for you to
add secrets whether you're running it
locally or remotely on google cloud
to start i've created a python flask
cloud run service with one of cloud
code samples it's a simple hello world
example
i've enabled the secret manager api for
my gcp project
added the secret manager library to my
requirements.txt file
and coded up an extra function that
returns the latest version value of a
secret
all the secret manager actions happen in
the secret manager panel
from here you can view a project's
existing secrets and create new secrets
to create a secret click the add button
and provide a name and value
now that my secret has been created it
shows up in the secret manager panel
to view the value of your secret version
go to the version tab
right-click a version and select view
secret value
to access the secret's latest version
value from my service
i'm going to replace this message with a
call to the access secret version
function i added
in my secret manager panel i can right
click a secret
and get its secret id
and then stick it in the parameters
now it's time to see if this works on my
service locally
on cloud code's cloud run emulator check
the link in the description with info on
how to do this
setup only takes a second for local
development
accessing this secret from cloud code's
cloud run emulator
automatically works no need to worry
about authentication
and there we have it the contents of my
secret
i can also create a new version of my
secret by right clicking it and
selecting new version
since the function i added grabs the
latest secret version by default
i can refresh my service and see my new
secret value
that's a quick look at cloud code secret
manager support if you have any
questions or feature requests about
cloud code
join our slack channel